did you know that you can build a Google
quality search app using your own data
and get $1,000 credit to try it out and
embed that search bar in your web page
or app with vertex AI search now
generally available Enterprise
developers can quickly ingest data add
customization and build a generative AI
powered search engine in hours and days
instead of weeks and months this search
experience is similar to Google's
generative search experience and we've
also introduced new connectors to help
developers connect to Common Enterprise
apps like Salesforce jira and Confluence
for data access the best part is
grounding which means search results are
rooted in your data and come with
citations and links that boost user
confidence and the accuracy of the
results shown organizations can decide
if they want this data to be
supplemented with the foundation model's
training data and yes for a limited time
we're offering $1,000 credit for
developers to try out vertex AI search
check out our pricing page for more
details